this Memorial Day weekend as we honor
more than a million servicemen and women
who sacrifice their lives to defend our
nation and our freedoms we come
face-to-face with hard evidence that the
deep state planned to take down our duly
elected president a deep state from
President Obama on down that did
everything in its power to destroy
Donald Trump the latest a spy placed in
the Trump campaign sounds loony well
last year we thought you'd have to be
wearing a tinfoil hat to believe
President Trump when he said that he'd
been wired tapped and now we know secret
surveillance was conducted on at least
seven trumpet OC 'it's an unmasking of
americans done at a 350 percent increase
in the presidential election year by
obama deep Staters and now we find out a
spy was placed by the FBI in a trump
campaign you can be sure that there's
more as the DOJ and FBI fight the
release of information sought by
Congress so will they ever admit there
was a spy it's best I can tell it's made
up I don't know where he's getting that
from honestly you find that to be at all
possible or probable and I just play
devil's advocate that there was a spy
inserted into his campaign by an
intelligence agency I don't find it
possible and I know it not to be true I
think is very typical of mr. Trump to
mischaracterize he's a master of
mischaracterization and dishonesty to
label someone as a spy when they're a
confidential human source I think is
doing a disservice to these individuals
but also to the FBI but like most Liars
they can't keep their stories straight
clapper on the other hand pretty much
admits there was a spy and he things
Trump should be grateful was the FBI
spying on Trump's campaign no they were
not they were spying on a term I don't
particularly like but on what the
Russians were doing trying to understand
were the russians infiltrating trying to
gain access trying to gain leverage and
influence what they do so why doesn't he
like that he should be happy though
if ever you weren't sure who to believe
I've got to make this real easy for you
the Obama administration was so
determined to get Hillary Clinton
elected and Donald Trump defeated that
they let Hillary skate on her criminal
activity and created a narrative of
criminal activity on the part of Donald
Trump
they created a false predicate a made-up
dossier paid for by Hillary Clinton the
DNC and the FBI in order to get a court
to approve spying on Trump's campaign
and they were allowed to spy on the
campaign for a year they kept it close
only the highest level of the FBI not
the field offices the highest levels
work together to take Trump down they
planned insurance in the event their
girl Hillary didn't win they leaked
information harmful to Donald Trump to
the press and it was a head of the FBI
at the behest of James clapper who
privately told the president about the
fake dossier so that they could leak it
to the press and the world so who you
gonna believe take a look at this chart
they're all liars James Comey the head
of the FBI lied about whether he had
ever been an anonymous source in news
reports about the Trump or Clinton
investigations he replied never but mr.
leaker himself had to admit that he did
so Comey also lied before Congress when
he testified that he briefed the
president about the dossier because he
learned the media was about to report on
it
in truth Comey briefed Trump for the
very purpose of getting that dossier out
to the public and Comey said his
investigation of Hillary was thorough
in truth he wrote an exoneration memo
long before essential witnesses were
even interviewed and of course his
deputy director Andrew McCabe that I
didn't even put on my chart lied so many
times the guy had to be fired and to get
someone to fire and that agency is
amazing an attorney general Loretta
Lynch who pushed to call the Clinton
investigation a matter lied when she
said there were no emails between her
Department and the FBI when she used an
email
with a fake name to write about her
infamous tarmac meeting with former
President Clinton James clapper another
who the director of the National
Intelligence Agency pretty much lies
whenever he opens his mouth like when he
lied before Congress and answered to a
quite direct question about whether or
not his agency collected data on
hundreds of millions of Americans he
said no not wittingly he also lied about
the Trump dossier saying he never leaked
it to CNN he since admitted that he did
and now he's on CNN's payroll John
Brennan head of the CIA lied and said
the Steele dossier was not part of the
intelligence community's to have
evidence on Russian interference in the
2016 election and again Liars not being
able to keep their stories straight
he was contradicted by clapper now you
remember Susan Rice her lying started
long before Benghazi in that despicable
video she also lied and said that in the
final days of the Obama administration
she knew nothing about the surveillance
of president-elect Trump and people
around him and she knew nothing about
identities being unmasked shortly
thereafter she came clean telling house
investigators she unmasked senior Trump
officials and the big kahuna at the top
just before the inauguration President
Obama created new rules that allowed
intelligence historically protected
within one agency to be spread across at
least 16 agencies signaling to his
people let it all hang out and leak your
heart away on Trump so I for one am sick
and tired of these Liars leakers and
liberals attacking our president and our
democracy when they are the ones who
tried to frame him here's a primer for
all of you if you're gonna set up a
president to try to frame him do it
against someone who's dumber than you
are